at the beginning of our presidency
indeed before our presidency we had
announced that two of our major
priorities were the issue of childhood
obesity and the issue of cross-border
cooperation with health systems today we
have to say that we have adopted council
conclusions on both priorities obesity
is a European challenge and must be
addressed not just by health ministers
and the health council but across the
whole of the European Union and its
institutions the second conclusions
conclusions that were adopted today
regarded reven voluntary cross-border
cooperation and again this is a very
important concept and I think there is
much scope for for collaboration between
member states especially on a voluntary
basis in the coming months and years the
provision of health services is member
state competence and must remain as such
however having said that there is a
large scope for collaboration between
institutions and and and member states
across the European Union the third item
that we discussed today was the health
aspect on the applications to health
generated by the European pillar of
social rights I'm particularly glad we
had an opportunity to discuss health
aspects of European pillar of social
rights looking at the health principle I
would like to highlight that timely
access means everyone should be able to
access health care whenever they need it
affordable health care means people
should not be prevented from getting the
care they need because of the course
health care good quality means that
health care should be relevant
appropriate safe and effective